kamala harris will be the first female
vice president the first
black vice president and the first asian
american vice president that's a lot of
first during her acceptance speech on
saturday
she honored all the women who came
before her and courageously fought
to protect and secure the right to vote
saying this i stand
on their soul on their shoulders nicole
killian is in wilmington delaware with a
look at how the vice president-elect has
broken barriers
throughout her entire career
as president-elect joe biden claimed
victory he and his running mate
made history while i may be the first
woman in this office
i will not be the last
vice president-elect kamala harris heads
back to washington as the first woman
on a winning presidential ticket what a
testament it is
to joe's character that he had the
audacity
to break one of the most substantial
barriers
that exist in our country and select a
woman as his vice president
she was born in oakland as the daughter
of two immigrants
an economics professor from jamaica and
a breast cancer researcher from
india crediting her mother for paving
the way
when she came here from india at the age
of 19 she maybe
didn't quite imagine this moment but
she believed so deeply in america
where a moment like this is possible
harris graduated from historically black
howard university
where she pledged alpha kappa alpha the
first black greek letter sorority
from there she blazed a trail of first
as san francisco's district attorney
then california's attorney general and
in 2017
she became a u.s senator as a child of
immigrants
she knows personally how immigrant
families enrich our country
as well as the challenges of what it
means to grow up black and indian
american in the united states of america
harris has said she often draws her
words and inspiration from political
powerhouse shirley chisholm
the first black woman from a major
political party to run for president
i am not the candidate of black america
although i am black and proud
only two other women have run as vice
presidential nominees of a major party
i will be honored to accept your
nomination for vice president
of the united states republican
presidential candidate john mccain
selected sarah palin
as his running mate in 2008 and in 1984
democratic congresswoman geraldine
ferraro made history
alongside walter mondale america
is the land where dreams can come true
for all of us nearly 40 years later
harris hopes to inspire a new generation
to the children of our country
regardless of your gender
our country has sent you a clear message
dream with ambition lead
with conviction and see yourselves in a
way that others may not
simply because they've never seen it
before
one of harris's close friends told me
she is over the moon another cried on
the phone this is a history making
ticket
across the board harris's husband will
be the first man to serve as a second
spouse dr
jill biden who has said she plans to
resume teaching will be the first first
lady to work
outside of the white house and
president-elect biden will be the second
catholic president
and the oldest to take office guys wow
so many firsts there and there's the
first shelter dog in the white house
too major that's major but that's okay
i'm named after major
not named after major garrett that would
be a compliment i actually think yes
but i mean imagine you want to be in
jill biden's class
if if you have the chance but i keep
thinking about kamala harris it's so
important to see women that look like
you
yeah to let you know what is possible
that's why this is so
huge for young girls and women of color
to see that this has happened and i know
for teachers because my wife is having a
teacher
in the white house is really cool too
yeah and i will say there's a long list
of things to be impressed by uh but
something that i want to point out that
others might not appreciate is uh a doug
and kamala blending of family and having
step kids who apparently love her they
call her mamala
and has a good relationship with the
with the mom like all that is
complicated as can be probably as
complicated as dealing with a senate
that may not be uh
of your party uh really is a modern on
that stage the other night guys you just
saw
family yeah it was like a great benetton
ad
all these many colors and functional and
functional yeah
and functional yes to make it work
but i also think it's important i always
keep saying this that as happy as some
people are a lot of people are not happy
that's right
we've got to figure out how you know how
you unite the country under these
circumstances
that's very very important yeah but
regardless of party
regardless of party bringing a family
together through divorce yes
complicated job well done all right
hello my name is tony
i know there's the viewers out there
know what i'm talking about all right
a little too well nicole thank you very
much